hi
i'm shannon from khan academy and i want
to show you
how to make the most of your learning
time
first make sure you're logged in to your
khan academy account
by checking for your name in the upper
right hand corner
now on the left side you should see your
classes where your teacher has given you
a mastery goal
or assignment to work on click on the
tab that says
course mastery to view the goal your
teacher set for you
now that you're viewing your goal let's
talk about the top
five things to know about working
towards course mastery
on khan academy number one
your course mastery placement is a big
goal from your teacher
on your learner homepage you can see the
progress
you've already made towards your mastery
goal and the due date your teachers set
but you can always work ahead or view
past goals
click on the mastery goal to be taken to
the course
homepage here you'll see the units that
make
up the course as well as your progress
towards mastery
on each unit as you make progress on
each unit
you'll see the purple bar fill from left
to right
it's helpful to regularly check your
unit progress so you know if you're on
track to meet your goal
click into a unit to view your current
mastery level for each skill
on the left hand side with
every skill try to get the crown and
move your mastery level to mastered
number two mastery takes time
and practice as you practice skills and
answer questions your mastery level for
each skill
will go up if you answer correctly or
down if you miss questions
if you want to make progress more
quickly try a mastery challenge
mastery challenges allow you to
strengthen the skills you've already
practiced
in just 6 questions
mastery is not easily earned and that's
intentional
but putting in the work to achieve
mastery will prove
you've earned and learned it remember
you can retry and exercise as many times
as you'd like
until you earn a score you're happy with
struggles and mistakes are what helps
your brain grow
[Music]
number three follow the blue button
your big goal has a lot of skills you
can practice
at your own pace to make sure you stay
on track
look for the blue buttons throughout the
course
the blue buttons will always guide you
to what you should work on next
number four if you're stuck take a hint
it's normal to feel stuck when you're
learning new skills
the important thing is you don't give up
take a hint to get step-by-step
instructions
to the specific question you're working
on and write them down so you can
reference them later
you can also try watching a video or
reading an article on the skill
once you've done that you're ready to
retry the exercise
and if you're still stuck reach out to
your classmate
a teacher or a family member for support
[Music]
number five the sky is the limit
remember you have the potential to
succeed
keep trying keep making mistakes and
keep
asking for help when you need it there
is no limit to what you can learn